ALISTAIR POTT: Hi, everyone.
So I am Alistair.
I lead the commerce
team in Google Play.
And I'm going to talk a bit
about commerce in general,
and subscriptions in
particular, something
that we're very,
very excited about.
What is commerce?
What is our vision?
So this sentence is
kind of a mouthful.
The way we think about
this is like, Play
is this gigantic, gigantic
digital marketplace, so
over a billion users out there,
like millions of developers
or millions of apps out there.
[INAUDIBLE] those people.
And a marketplace is
about transactions.
It's about linking those
buyers, linking those sellers,
making those
transactions happen.
That's what our team is about.
Our aim is to build
energy in that flywheel.
More buyers equals more sellers.
More sellers equals more buyers.
And so when we wake
up in the morning,
we're thinking about building
energy in that ecosystem.
That's what commerce is
about in Google Play.
We love to have strategic
pillars or tenets.
And Larissa briefly
touched on these, the ways
that we think about
the commerce platform.
So number one is reach.
In that previous slide, we
had the the word "ubiquitous"
and the word "global."
Our business is built,
Android is built,
on massive, massive reach-- well
over a billion users out there.
We aim to make it possible
for every one of those users
to transact on Google Play.
And I'm going to tell
you a little bit more
about the things that
we do in that space.
The second is conversion.
Once you've built an app
or built an experience that
is causing the user to
enter a transaction flow,
our team makes
sure that the user
comes out the end of
that transaction flow
having made a purchase.
So conversion is
a huge, huge deal.
We have a whole team of people.
Again, when they're brushing
their teeth in the morning,
they're thinking about
how to increase conversion
in your apps.
We also think about trust.
Actually, David, who
leads the trust team,
is going to be giving a talk on
what he calls fair play later
on today.
This ecosystem is built
on repeat transactions.
Our users make tens,
hundreds, sometimes thousands
of transactions
in the ecosystem.
This is real money.
These are real experiences.
We are like a retail platform.
We have to build and
maintain trust for our users.
And so we focus a lot on that.
And then the last
tenet is growth.
We believe that there are
things that Google Play can
do to drive energy
in this ecosystem.
We can put the right offers
in front of the right users
at the right times.
And so we've got a
growth team that's
also focusing on building
energy in that flywheel.
So we talked about reach.
So we have huge,
huge, huge reach.
This stuff is hard.
So we have transactions
enabled in over 130 countries.
And we have lots and lots
of local forms of payments.
So credit cards are great.
That's awesome.
But the fact of the
matter is that there's
a huge number of users
out there who do not
have access to a credit card.
And we need to make it
possible for those users
to transact on our platform.
I always talk to the team about
some farmer in rural Indonesia
who doesn't have access to a
credit card, who doesn't even
have a bank account.
How are we going to make
it possible for that person
to make a transaction
on the platform?
So one of the things we've
done is direct carrier billing,
or DCB.
At I/O, we announced that we've
crossed over 100 carriers.
Just a few months
later, we're actually
a bit over 115 carriers
around the world who have
direct carrier billing enabled.
What this means is that a user
who doesn't have that credit
card, who doesn't have access to
a traditional form of payment,
can make transactions
in your apps.
This stuff is hard.
I'll be honest with you.
Just recently, I
was having my brain
melted by the requirements
for direct carrier billing
in Kuwait.
But it's worth it, because
once we figured that out,
and once we launched direct
carrier billing in Kuwait,
buyer growth suddenly took off.
Conversion took off.
Everything took off in Kuwait.
So we have a big team that
wakes up and thinks about this
all the time.
And now we have more
than 600 million devices
around the world
which have access
to direct carrier billing.
So you'll have access to
those to sell to those users.
Subscriptions-- so
subscriptions is a huge deal.
We think this is the
next big business
model for in-app billing.
So over the last
few years, we've
seen massive, massive growth
in the subscriptions ecosystem.
And the fact of
the matter is this
is a great way for you
to monetize your apps.
If you're selling a service
or ongoing access to content,
it's much better to build
it as a recurring service
than to sell it one time
and support it forever.
So we're seeing a lot of
adoption of the subscriptions
business model.
Many developers
are getting bored.
And as a result, we're
seeing massive growth.
We think this can
easily continue
in the future, this
enormous growth.
So we focus extremely,
extremely hard on subscriptions.
We're seeing a lot of
developers getting on board.
Many of you in the room are
subscriptions business models,
and so we love working with you.
As you can tell, we're
focusing on this.
You'll see more
and more developers
on this slide in years going
forwards across a million
different business models.
So again, you can tell I
love strategic pillars.
The subscriptions team
also has strategic pillars.
And we're going to talk
about each of these
in a little more detail.
So the first is integration.
We want to make it easy
for developers or sellers
such as yourselves to integrate
with our subscriptions
platform.
We've made some good progress.
We've got a long way to go.
We'll talk about that.
We also want to make sure
that sign-up really, really,
really works for you.
This is our strongest area,
largely to do with that reach.
And we'll talk about
that in more detail.
Subscriptions are the
gift that keeps on giving,
but only if you can
retain those subscribers.
So retention is a
huge, huge deal for us.
This stuff is tricky, and
we have a big team focused
entirely on driving retention.
And then lastly, running
or managing a subscriptions
business is tough.
It's a lot of
data-based information.
You need to really be
looking at your cohorts.
And we want to make that
easy for you as well.
So I mentioned
briefly integration.
If you're a simple developer
or a mobile-first developer,
integrating with our
subscriptions platform
is extremely, extremely easy.
It's like any other
in-app billing.
But we're aware that many
of you are multi-platform.
You have a very sophisticated
order management system
behind what you're doing.
And so sometimes, integrating
with us can be a bit of a pain.
And so the integration
team is working
on making that easier--
building features
for you to make
it easier for you
to integrate with our
platform and to run
your business on our platform.
And we'll talk a bit about some
of the features that are coming
up in this space as well.
Sign-up-- this is the big one.
Sign-up is a huge,
huge deal for us.
The conversion team is
thinking about this.
And this is also where the
reach team comes into account.
So there are two things.
The one is, do we have
access to a form of payment
that the user also
has access to?
And that's where
this direct carrier
billing comes into account.
We have gift cards
in over 30 countries.
We have PayPal in
many countries.
We have local forms of
payment in other countries.
So does the user
have access to a form
of payment is a huge deal.
Otherwise, they just cannot
convert in your experience.
And then the second thing is we
actually have a lot of buyers.
We have huge numbers of
people who have already
added a form of payment to
the Google Play ecosystem who
are already
accustomed to walking
through this experience.
And those users also convert
at much, much higher rates.
So we see a lot of
success in this space.
And a good example of this
is our friends at CBS.
After integrating with the
Google Play subscriptions
platform, their sign-up
conversion went up enormously.
They saw far more users
entering on their platform
as a result of the reach and
as a result of the conversion.
There's a whole conversion
team in Google Play just making
this purchase flow work
better and better and better.
Another example is
Coffee Meets Bagel.
They started off using the
subscriptions business model.
And now 20% of their
revenue is on subscriptions.
So this is another
good example of success
building a
subscriptions-based business
and using the Google Play
subscriptions platform.
Coming soon is a feature
that many, many of you
have been asking for.
This is a good way to
drive down the friction
in that sign-up flow.
So we already have free trials.
But a lot of the time,
what you actually want
is a highly-qualified user.
So you don't want it
to be entirely free,
but you do want a very low price
for that first few-- [? 1n ?]
subscription period.
So introductory pricing is very,
very, very close to launching.
It's being tested at the moment.
And you'll be able to
use this to convert
more people into subscribers
at a lower price.
And then they'll automatically
revert to the full price
after as many
periods as you like.
So retention-- this
is a big, big deal.
Ultimately, you are providing
the value to the users.
You're building the motivation.
The user wants to
subscribe in order
to retain access to your
service or to your content.
So you're building
that motivation.
Some of the time, however,
something goes wrong.
The user's credit card expires
or the payment network is down,
and we suffer what's
called involuntary churn.
This is bad.
This is really bad.
We do not want this
to happen ever.
And so we have an entire team
focused on involuntary churn.
We think about all of churn.
We want to partner with you
to prevent voluntary churn.
But the thing that
these guys are thinking
about when I see
them in the morning
is involuntary churn and
fighting involuntary churn.
There are two main things
that you can do in this space.
So the one is retries.
And so we've got a
retries team that's
figuring out the right
ways to retry the charges.
Now because we have so many
different forms of payment
in so many different countries,
the regulations change,
the rules change.
And frankly, the interactions
with those forms of payment
change as well.
So this team is figuring
out exactly the right time
to retry a charge, when
to retry it, how often
to retry it to get
the highest recovery
rate possible through retries.
And then the second
thing that we
do to fight involuntary
churn is we actually
reach out to the users.
Sometimes, a retry is
just not going to work.
That form of payment is broken.
And so we need to reach out
to the user and tell the user,
listen, there's been a problem.
We need you to take some action.
And so very, very
recently, we actually
launched push notifications
from the Play Store
to users to tell them that
their subscription is broken
and that they should
come and take action.
And again, we've
seen improvements.
So I'm very excited about
the progress we've made.
But frankly, this team keeps
on coming up with ideas.
They keep on eking out
more and more recoveries.
And so I think that
there's even more upside
in the future in this space.
So we're going to
continue focusing on it.
Management-- ultimately,
we want to make it easy
for you to run your
subscriptions business.
We want to build tools.
We have a lot of
internal analytics
on the subscriptions
products and businesses,
and we want to start
surfacing those.
And so you should see
that coming very soon.
And the developer
console will be
releasing additional
subscriptions-focused reporting
and management tools.
So that was a very
brief overview.
As I say, I'm going
to be around all day.
We have an engineering lead
and other product managers
on the subscriptions team today.
Look out for them.
I can introduce you to them.
We think about integration,
so we've got new APIs
coming out all the time.
We want to make it much easier
to manage your subscription
SKUs.
And in particular,
we know that it's
difficult to manage the
pricing of these SKUs.
So we're working very hard
on things like price changes
and on dynamic pricing
of subscription products.
Sign-up is a big deal for us.
Obviously, we've got the reach
team who just continually
is working on new
forms of payment.
We've got some very
exciting forms of payment
in Europe and in
India coming up.
We've got the DCB team, the
Direct Carrier Billing team,
always working on this stuff.
We've got free trials.
We've got local pricing.
We've got very low
prices in some countries.
And coming extremely soon,
we've got introductory pricing
launching.
So I encourage you
to test that out.
On retention, we've got
that retention team.
Honestly, these
guys are the guys
I go and see every morning.
We've got to drive up the
retention rates for all of you.
Then subscriptions become the
gift that keeps on giving.
We have been testing
our promotion codes.
So you'll be hearing
from your BD managers
about working with us on
subscription promotions.
We want to be able to do that.
We have been working
with intelligent retries.
There's some very
interesting work there.
We've got grace
periods, which have
been shown to make a huge
difference to retention,
mostly because it gives us
more time to do those retries.
We've seen huge improvements
when grace period is enabled.
And as I said, we've just
launched push notifications,
the very first version.
We're going to iterate
on this to drive the user
to fix more subscriptions.
And then finally, we've got
teams working on the management
tools-- in particular,
those churn metrics.
As you can tell, I'm
pretty obsessed with churn.
So we've got a lot of
reporting in that space,
and we're going to be
releasing that in the developer
console coming soon as well.
Thank you.